تجمع دول النيه بالقرب من روسيا انضمام
السويد واوكرانيا للحلف ابرز المحاور
سامي
صراع السوداني بلا افق وهي من رايت تدعو
لتحقيق دولي في الجرائم
[موسيقى]
الامير العام حلف الناتو اعرب عن ثقته في
ان البيان الختامي القمه ليتوانيا سيبعث
برساله ايجابيه بشان مسار اوكرانيا
للانضمام وقال في ندوه حواريه قبل انطلاق
القمه اليوم ان اوكرانيا اصبحت قريبه
للغايه من حلف الناتو وانا الوقت حان
لينعكس ذلك على قرارات الحلف وشدد على ان
قمه ستتخذ قرارات قويه لدعم
في ردود الفعل الروسيه مشاهدينا تجاه قمه
نيتو حذر السفير الروسي لدعم
من ان استراتيجيه حلف الناتو ستزيد من
مخاطر الصراع المباشر بين روسيا ودوي
الحلف واضاف ان خطه الدفاع الاقليميه التي
ينوي الناتو تبنيها في قمه ليتوانيا ستجعل
المواجهه بين روسيا والحلف اكثر توترا
واطول ابدا
ومن العاصمه مشاهدينا معنا موفد العربي
الى هناك
وصباح الخير الجدول الاعمال اذن منتخب
مجموعه من التفاصيل المهمه والمصريه في
هذه القمه اضعنا في صوره العناوين العريضه
لهذه القمه اليوم في في
صباح الخير احمد هذه القمه في الحقيقه
تتركز حول مساله اساسيه هي حرب اوكرانيا
هي مستقبل عضويه اوكرانيا هي الامن
الاوروبي بعد نهايه هذه الحرب الجاريه بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا في هذه اللحظات
الدبلوماسيون يواجهون صعوبات او يحاولون
ايجاد السياحه المناسبه التي تستجيب لما
تطالب به اوكرانيا وهي العضويه مئه بالمئه
والكامله في حلف شمال الاطلسي
والتحفظات الاخرى من خاصه من جانب الدول
الكبيره
في الحلف اي بريطانيا المانيا بشكل اساسي
فرنسا الولايات المتحده هاتها الدول لها
مسؤوليات في الامن الدولي وفي الامن
الاوروبي لا تريد اطلاقا اتخاذ اي خطوه من
شانها ان تؤدي الى استفزاز الجانب الاخر
او ان تؤدي الى الوصول الى ما يسمى
في الامن الاطلسي اوروبي الاطلسي الخطوط
الحمراء وهي عدم المواجهه او عدم الوصول
الى خط المواجهه بين حلف الناتو وروسيا
وعدم الوصول الى خط المواجهه او اتخاذ
مبادرات من شانها ان تدفع روسيا الى
استخدام السلاح النووي عندما اذا تعرضت
لمخاطر لوجودها مثل ما تقول العقيده
الدفاعيه الروسيه من هنا فان لا شك من ان
حل ان اوكرانيا ستكون عضوا في حلف شمال
الاطلسي ما يتخذ من اجراءاته تقريبا كانها
تمد لهذه العضويه على سبيل المثال ما قاله
الامين العام
وحتى قبل لحظات من ان حلف شمال الاطلسي
سيضع يضع مخطط طويل الامدي لاعاده اصلاحي
وبناء القوات الاوكرانيه وفق مواصفات
الجيوش الغربيه هذه المخططات في الحقيقه
هي تمهد اوكرانيا للعضويه الكامله حتى انه
قال في الوقت المناسب اوكرانيا لن تحتاج
الى مرحله انتقاليه للانقراض في عضويه
الحلف هذا بعد ان تزوجت القمه البارحه
العقبه السويديه
ونتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره من مطار
مطار حيث ستعقد اليوم هذه القمه الهامه
وسيصل الرؤساء ورؤساء الحكومات تباعا في
هذا عبر هذا المطار الى هذه المدينه لتعقد
هذه القمه المهمه المنتظره والتي ايضا كما
ذكرنا هي توصف التاريخيه لحلف العاصمه
التطوانيه
وهناك محاور عده طبعا
ستناقش وتتداول في هذه القمه على راسها
انضمام السويد واوكرانيا للحلف كما افادها
قبل قليل الزميل انور الدين الفور نكمل
معك هناك ايضا حديث عن التحضيرات امنيه
وصفت بغير المسبوقه في بريلياس تحسبا لاي
تطورات قد تطورت امنيه بطبيعه الحال قد
تحدث اليوم ماذا يمكن ان تحدثنا عن ذلك
عبر مشاهداتك
فعلا يعني المدينه او ربما البلد ككل تحول
الى منطقه امنيه عسكريه يعني بمجرد ان
تقترب من الطائره من الوصول حتى ترى
منافذه الطائره بطريات بطاريات صواريخ
الامريكيه التي تشغلها المانيا لحمايه
القمه وفي الحقيقه لان المانيا تقود
الكاتبات القتاليه الاطلسيه لحمايه
الاسبانيا هنا
والمجمع الذي تعقد فيه القمه او
الوفود الدبلوماسيه
والمئات اكثر من الف صحفي
تحولت المنطقه تقريبا الى فتنه عسكريه
تحميها اسلحه يعني اسلحه ثقيله ايضا يعني
هناك اسلحه مدفعيه شاهد في بعض النواحي من
المدينه هذا اضافه الى مناطق محظوره تماما
عن الماره او الطرقات المغلقه في هذا
البلد الرئيس الرئيس لوتوانيا
من ان بلاده لا تقعوا بعيدا عن منسك
عاصمته بيلاروسيا وهو يخشى من نشر فاجنر
المرتزقه مرتزقه في روسيا في بيلاروسيا او
ان الاخيره تحتضن اسلحه تكتيكيه روسيا يدل
على المخاطر والاحساس القوي بالخوف مما قد
يحدث في المستقبل
شكرا لك نور الدين الفريضي مراسل العربيه
او موفت العربيه الى العاصمه
ونبقى في ليتوانيا مشاهدينا حيث اكد
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
العربيه اكد على عدم وجود صفقه بانضمام
تركيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي مقابل موافقه
انخر على ضم السويد لحلف الناتوب واضاف
سوليفان ان امريكا تدعم مطالبه تركيا
بانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن عليها
انتفى بالشروط اللازمه
قبل ذلك اعلن ماثيو ميلار المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكي عن دعم بلاده لبيع
مقاتله اف 16 لانقره الخارجيه شددت على ان
بيع المقاتلات التركيه وعضويه السويد في
حلف الناتو قضيتان منفصلتان مؤكده على دعم
اهداف تركيا بشان الاتحاد الاوروبي
دفعت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارينبير
عن قرار اداره بايدن بالتزويد اوكرانيا
بذخائر عنقوديه وقالت في تصريح العربيه ان
هذا القرار لن يؤدي الى انقسام في حلف
الناتو وان تحالف دعم اوكرانيا سيظل قويا
واشارت الى ان اوكرانيا لن تتمكن من
الدفاع عن نفسها الا بالحصول على دخاير
عنقوديه
وبتطورات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كشفت
هيئه الاركان الاوكراني ان سلاح الجو نفذ
خمسه عشره غاره على مواقع وتمركزات للقوات
الروسيه خلال 24 ساعه واشارت الى معارك
عنيفه دائره في اتجاهات باكموت ونيماسك
وصلت الى 30 اشتباكا قتاليا وقالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان الدفاعات اسقطت سته
بل 26 من اصل 28 مسير اطلقتها روسيا خلال
الليل كما اكدت ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تستمر في شن عمليات هجوميه في
اتجاهاتسك وتتمسك بالمكاسب التي حققتها
قصف ودمار في اوكرانيا يقابله بذخ في
روسيا ليس عند الجميع فقط عند بوتين
والمقربين منه وثائق سريه حصلت عليها سي
ان ان تكشف تفاصيل خاصه عن حياه الرئيس
الروسي وقطاره الخاص
قطار بوتين كنز من المعلومات السريه عن
حياه فلاديمير بوتين المرفهه
مركز مختص في التحقيقات الاستقصائيه عن
روسيا كشفت تفاصيل حول حياه الطرف
والرفاهيه التي يعيشها الرئيس الروسي
الخامس من اغسطس عام 2022 في الوقت نفسه
الذي كان الجيش الروسي يقصف اهدافا
اوكرانيه اجتمعت اداره الكريملان للاتفاق
حول تجهيز عربه قطار بوتين بمعدات رياضيه
تمكن الرئيس من ممارسه الرياضه على متن
قطاره المصفح
القطار يشبه كل القطارات الروسيه كنوع من
التمويه ولكنه الوحيد الذي يستعمل قاطعتين
اضافه الى كونه مجهزا بهوائي متطور
للاتصالات حتى يستطيع بوتين اصدار الاوامر
لجيشه اوكرانيا وهو يستمتع بحصه تدليك في
عربه المنتجع الصحي طبعا صممت العربات
الخاصه بالرئيس بشكل يمنع التنصت التنقل
عبر القطار هو امر نابع عن هاجس السريه
لدى
فحسب ما كشفه ددوسيسانتا بوتين لجا للتنقل
بالقطار نظرا لصعوبه رصده خلافا للطائره
الرئاسيه التي تصبح تحركاتها مكشوفه في
اللحظه التي تقلع فيها
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
احتجاجا على التغيير القضائي محتج
اسرائيليون في تل ابيب يغلقون الطرق
المؤديه الى القدس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد الى الصراع في
السودان حيث دعت منظمه هيومن رايت المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه الى التحقيق في اعمال
القتل والنهب على ايدي قوات الدعم السريع
والميليشيات العربيه في ولايه غرب دارفور
في السودان ووافقه المنظمه من خلال شهود
عيان اعدام ثمانيه وعشرين شخصا على الاقل
من اثنيه المساليد في الهجوم على بلده
مستري في 28 من مايو الماضي وبحسب المنظمه
ترقى ترقى العديد من هذه الانتهاكات التي
تشبه ما حدث قبل عشرين عاما ترقى الى
جرائم حرب مناشده باتخاذ ردود دوليه اقوى
لصراع الاخر في التساع وتظهر الاحصاءات
نزوح اكثر من 300 الف شخص داخل غرب دارفور
وحدها وفرار نحو 180 الفا الى
قبل ذلك قال السفير الامريكي في الخرطوم
جانجوت في ان الانتصار العسكري لاي من
الطرفين المتحاربين في السودان ستترتب
عليه خسائر بشريه غير مقبوله وفي تغريده
على تويتر حث السفير الامريكي طرفي الصراع
في السودان على ايجاد مخرج تفاوضي من
الازمه لتقليل الضرر الذي لحق بالبلاد
هذا هو عباره قوى الحريه والتغيير
السوداني عن اسفها لقرار الجيش السوداني
عدم المشاركه في اجتماع اللجنه الرباعيه
لدول المنظمه الحكوميه للتنميه الايجاد
المعنيه بحل الازمه السودانيه واعلنت
القوه ترحيبها بالتاكيد المجتمعين من
القوى الاقليميه والدوريه في اديس ابا على
العمل على انهاء الحرب واشراك المدنيين
واضافت انها تدعم كل الجهود المبذوله من
قبل السعوديه وامريكا
ومبادره الايجاد الهادفه لانهاء الحرب في
السودان
رئيس
ان اجتماع بشان السودان حتى طرفي الصراع
على اعلان وقف غير مشروط لاطلاق النار ودع
الرئيس الكيني الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع للاتفاق على انشاء منطقه انسانيه
لتسهيل وصول المساعدات
يجب ان يمهد اجتماعنا لوقف غير مشروط
لاطلاق النار هذه الخطوه ستوقف الخسائر في
الارواح وستسهل وصول الشعب السوداني الى
الخدمات الاساسيه كما سيتيسر سبل تسويه
الصراع الوساطه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع يجب ان توقف الحرب ويجب ان
يتفق الطرفان على انشاء منطقه انسانيه
منح الكنيسه الاسرائيلي موافقه مبدئيه على
مشروع قانون قدمته الحكومه ويحد من
السلطات المحكمه العليا ويهيمن ائتلاف
نتنياهو على الاغلبيه في الكنيست هو فاز
في التصويت الاول من بين ثلاث عمليات
اقتراع مطلوبه لاقرار القانون ومن المتوقع
ان تشتد الاحتجاجات على المشروع اليوم في
ظل تعهد معارضي التعديلات بتنظيم مظاهرات
حال الموافقه عليها
هذا واغلق محتجون اسرائيليون الطرق
المؤديه الى القدس كما تظاهر الالاف منهم
في محيط المحكمه لمدينه حيفا في اطار ما
اطلقوا عليه يوم التشويش الهادف الى حل
الحركه في اسرائيل ومرافقها الحيويه لما
فيها المطار وذلك احتجاجا على انطلاق
عمليه التشريع خطه التغيير القضائي
الحكوميه
[موسيقى]
في القدسي ايضا مشاهدينا اقتحم مستوطنون
اسرائيليون منزل عائله صب لبن في عقبه
الخالديه بالبلده القديمه وسيطروا عليه
وذكر مراسل العربيه ان شاطر الصهيري معززه
بالوحدات الخاصه نصبت حواجز عسكريه عندما
مدخل عقبه الخالديه بالبلده القديمه وقامت
بحصار المنزل واقلته من السكان تمهيدا
لتسليمه للمستوطنين بقرار صادر عن محكمه
الاسرائيليه
حضر الاتحاد الاوروبي الشركات المالكه
لمنصه التواصل الاجتماعي من الحظر في دول
الاتحاد اذا لم تحدث اي محتوى يحرض على
العنف المفوض الاوروبي للسوق الداخلي قال
ان قانون الخدمات الرقميه الجديد سيدخل
حيز التنفيذ اعتبارا من نهايه اغسطس
المقبل وسيتطلب قيودا على المحتوى المحرض
على العنف ياتي تعليق بريتون لتصريحات
الرئيس الفرنسي مايويل ماكرون بحجب
المحتوى الذي يحرض على العنف للسيطره على
اعمال الشغب الاخيره التي شهدتها بلادهم
الذكاء الاصطناعي قادر على تسبب بجائحه او
حتى تطوير اسلحه بيولوجيه وفق دراسه لمعهد
التكنولوجيا الامريكي تجربه صادمه لفته
النظر الى التقييد على بيانات الذكاء
الاصطناعي وروبوتات نتابع
حوار لم تقف حدوده هنا ابعاده بات
ت روبوتات في اولى خطواتها نحو الاسلحه
البيولوجيه قادره على اقتراح مسببات
لامراض وبائيه والتخطيط لها اربعه
اقتراحات لصنع سلاح بيولوجي اخر الجهود
الصادمه لدردشه الذكاء الاصطناعي في معهد
تكنولوجي امريكي فما ان سال طالب حول طرق
التسبب بجائحه حتى انهالت اقتراحات قابله
للتطبيق في غضون ساعه اقتراحات يرافقها
شرح مفصل للتنفيذ ايضا شرح لصنع وباء من
الحمض النووي الاصطناعي بل وقدمت اسماء
لشركات للمساعده في تنفيذ الفكره رؤيه
علميه بعين الروبوت تضاهي قدره البشر في
الصناعه وتطوير اسلحه ليست سهله عمليا حمل
مستقبلي قدرته دول غربيه
بريطانيا التزمت بتمويل سنوي مليار
وخمسمائه مليون جنيه استرليني لمواجهه
التهديد بينما اختتم البنتاجون اول مراجعه
لوضعيه الدفاع البيولوجي تكميم افواه
الذكاء الاصطناعي عن المخاطر وازاله
البيانات البيولوجيه الضاره منها حلول
مطروحه لدى هيئات التطوير عالميا وايضا
تحويل التهديد الى مصدر للكشف المبكر عن
الاوبئه بدلا من صناعتها عبر عوالم
تكنولوجيه باتت تخفي بين جمالياتها افكارا
بيولوجيه غذاء السالم العربيه
طلب رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب من
المحكمه الفيدراليه تاجيل المحكمه في قضيه
وثائقو المدعون كانوا قد طلبوا التاجيل
حتى ديسمبر القادم لاعطاء الجانبين المزيد
من الوقت للاستعداد الا ان محامي ترامب
يحتج على التوقيت غير الكافي للاستعداد
حصلت امطار غزيره في ولايه
المتحده متسببه في حدوث فيضانات غير
مسبوقه في امريكا وثق فيها المدنيون كيف
بدت الشوارع امام منازلهم مغموره بالمياه
المنجرفه
[موسيقى]
قالت هيئه الارصاد الجويه في ايسلندا ان
بركانا بل ان بركان جنوب غربي البلاد بدا
بثوران يوم الاثنين وذلك بعد احد عشر شهرا
من انتهاء اخر ثور له رسميا
[موسيقى]
ولا مشاهدينا ونتابع معكم هذه الصور
المباشره من مقر انعقاد قمه حلف شمال
الاطلسي في العاصمه الليتوانيه نشاهد الان
مراسم الاستقبال للرئيس الامريكي
فيلاينياس الرئيس التواني ايضا مشاهدينا
كما تابعنا ونتابع الان جيتانا يستقبل
الرئيس الامريكي الذي يراس الوفد الامريكي
المشارك في قمه الناتو
مشاهدينا في متابعه هذه الصور لوصول
الرئيس الامريكي
المشاركه في قمه الناتو هذه القمه
المنتظره والتي توصف بالتاريخيه لحلف شمال
الاطلسي في العاصمه الالكترونيه فيلينيوس
والتي ستشمل ايضا محاور عده تناقش في جدول
اعمال هذه القمه على راسها
انضمام السويد واوكرانيا للحلف رئيس
ليتواني مشاهدينا كان ايضا دعا حلف الناتو
الى ابطال القانون التاسيسي للعلاقات
والتعاون بين الحلف وموسكو الموقع عام
1997 واعتبر في حديث لصحيفه انه لم يعد
هناك معنى لقانون العلاقات والتعاون مع
روسيا بعد نشرها اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
مشاهدينا معكم في متابعه هذه الصور
المباشره
لاستقبال او مراسم استقبال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن في فيلينيوس للمشاركه
في قمه
النيتو وايضا مشاهدينا هذه القمه نتائج
حتى الان يعني ادت الى تصريحات غاضبه من
الجانب الروسي سناقشها في سياق النشاط
المقبله مثال هذه النشر المشاهدين الى
اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات